all right if you're looking for a way to
give back this holiday season the
catholic charities of southern nevada
needs your help
feeding the community especially our
seniors here's more information on their
food and nutrition services
i'm excited to talk about catholic
charities of southern nevada first and
foremost just introduce
us to the organization
we've been in uh business since 1941 so
we're about ready to approach our 80th
anniversary there aren't too many things
that are 80 years old in southern nevada
congratulations
we help thousands of people every day
we'll talk about some of the food
programs that are a staple
for the agency but we also handle
shelter operations
and adoption services lots of great ways
to help people that
have needs in our community beautiful
and i know you mentioned the food and
nutrition so how are you guys helping
people during the holidays i know that's
a part of the program
there are really three legs to the to
the chair
of our food program uh one that is a big
one is
meals on wheels so we help over 2
400 seniors every day with meals on
wheels and that's
food that goes directly out from our
kitchens with our drivers and
refrigerated trucks
to the client directly and they get
seven meals at a time
during the pandemic we've had to leave
the meal at the door and call the client
to make sure that they get it
and then do a smile or a wave to the
client
we also provide pet food for people that
have pets so that they're not sharing
their food with their pets so
there's great needs there's still a
waiting list for meals on wheels
due to funding challenges so that's a
big program that helps
thousands of our seniors and that
program is growing this thanksgiving
will give out 3 000
turkeys and the fixins to all of our
needy clients
uh because of the pandemic we're having
to create social distancing
uh and try to keep that product safe as
it goes across the table to the clients
how people can donate uh funds or gift
cards to us to help us pay for that
product
uh because you might imagine the need
for food
during the pandemic is greater than it's
ever been absolutely and how does the
meals on wheels program actually work
how can people get involved or
apply to be a part of it you can go on
the website as well
and uh apply for the program uh the
all the information the contact
information the phone numbers to apply
for meals on wheels
basically if you're 60 years old and and
are in
need of food and have limited mobility
uh
unfortunately now you have to go on the
waiting list because funding is tight
that program as people in southern
nevada come here to rely
locate and retire and age in place that
need
goes up any encouraging words beacon
time for everybody during this time
this is an unprecedented year of
challenge but i also
think it's a time for us to be grateful
for our blessings uh
with those of us that have been able to
stay healthy or recover
and those of us that have been able to
continue to be innovative
to serve we have served every single day
at catholic charities despite the
pandemic
so that gives me hope to know that there
is an end in sight but until there is
uh let's stay hopeful and grateful for
our blessings and remember that
despite our challenges there are people
less fortunate than all of us
and when we give of ourselves it makes
more room in our heart for gratitude
great words by deacon tom thank you for
joining us catholic charities
of southern nevada is located at 1501
las vegas boulevard north you can call
that number right there on your screen
or simply visit catholiccharities.com to
donate
and learn more we'll be right back